on va changer d'univers vous restez avec
nous bien sûr sur le plateau on reste
dans la musique mais plutôt hard rock
métal avec notre invité que les
téléspectateurs ont sans doute déjà vu
sur ce plateau fred mériguet donc et qui
est chanteur du groupe du groupe malades
et sarthe
et puis marquisat qu'au bon soir vous
êtes donc responsable du service musique
amplifiée de la ville de montigny le
bretonneux vous préparer un concert avec
ce groupe concert qui aura lieu le 19
janvier là vous êtes en plein dans vos
missions c'est promouvoir les groupes
locaux
le groupe et de rambouillet c'est le but
premier est justement de du service
notre mission c'est d'accompagner les
groupes i ni mon teint dans leur projet
artistique c'est aussi de proposer vous
unit montain une série de concerts toute
l'année et donc de proposer des artistes
qui tourne déjà au niveau national dont
il ya des artistes locaux du sertit du
département mais aussi des artistes qui
tournent donc au niveau national et
parfois européen
donc notre mission elle est double
accompagner les projets artistiques et
les porter le plus loin possible et
proposer des spectacles de l'année
rosine et montrent un homme aussi aux
habitants de la communauté
d'agglomération petit dantès est assez
inédit parce que ça dépend de la ville
de montigny le bretonneux c'est assez
rare de trouver ça aussi dans une
commune comme ça s'est vérifié
absolument c'est assez rare et c'est
précieux et on
on est très conscient et on est
conscients aussi qu'il ya beaucoup de
demandes qui a beaucoup de talent donc
il ya beaucoup de travail pour essayer
de faire émerger tous ces talents parce
que le but c'est à la fois les
accompagner dans une cohérence
artistique mais c'est de la porter si au
regard des professionnels des diffuseurs
des distributeurs privés donc la mission
elle est très large et très ambitieuse
et justement ce secteur là s'adresse à
tous les types de musique ou via des
styles musicaux qui sont pas forcément
les bienvenus
oui je sais pas si c'est pas joli mais
c'est une très bonne question mais on
est un service municipal une
municipalité ne fait pas de
discrimination auprès de ses concitoyens
donc nous sommes amenés à travailler sur
tous les styles de musique sans aucune
différenciation ou discrimination et on
va parler du concert à venir le 19
janvier avec le groupe malatesta pour
ceux qui n'étaient pas avec nous en
novembre dernier lorsque vous êtes venu
nous parler de vos projets on va
regarder un extrait
plus fin
chez le groupe
jetez plus
pour
malatesta 19 janvier donc à montigny le
bretonneux quels sont les morceaux que
le public va pouvoir découvrir notre
futur nouvel album parce que vous êtes
en préparation d'un mobile fait qu'on
enregistrait justement au ceba 2 minimum
vous allez tester ses nouveaux morceaux
sur scène oui une pression pas du tout
pas du tout mais la trêve et c'est très
bien le groupe a évolué peu ces derniers
mois vous avez notamment accueillir un
nouveau membre
deux nouveaux membres est ce que c'est
c'est difficile de trouver un équilibre
c'est quelque chose qui se fait
naturellement on tâtonne un peu faux
début on tâtonne un peu au début au
niveau au niveau humain on a trouvé deux
nouveaux membres
vraiment excellent qui vont nous de
remonter justement au niveau au niveau
musical
ses membres s'appelle en ce qu'il a et
puis qui gagnent 6 et ça apporte quelque
chose d'avoir justement des nouveaux
membres viennent avec leurs univers
respectifs
oui démontre qu'on ne connaît pas du
tout et puis qui vaut certainement nous
apporte certains est pour le groupe un
pari risqué même parce que ouais un peu
rugueux vous ne connaissez pas mais tu
t'en fous tu es là aussi vous êtes seul
vous êtes toujours serein vous y étiez
toujours moment là vous êtes sera
l'album qui se prépare vous êtes sera le
concert vous êtes serra jeunes a été
impressionnée puis tu es toujours serein
justement donc de culturel entre la
musique c'est comme ça par rapport aux
concerts justement comment vous avez été
mis en relation avec la ville de
montagne bretonneux servi par benjamin
savignoni qui était notre premier ingé
son peu de mots la testa qui nous
enregistrer de notre premier rhdp quand
on a commencé il ya 13 ans maintenant
fait que le technicien son du sm a bola
dont l'importance de garder de vos
contacts pour continuer ensuite une
longue carrière
on va faire jusqu'à une structure on va
faire une petite poche voilà un peu plus
classique
will et les piano bars à tout le monde
connaît mais est-ce que les pianos gars
ça vous dit quelque chose
oui oui à quoi bon alors c'est en tout
cas ce initiative a été lancée par la
sncf ce qui paraît que la musique
adoucit les moeurs après montparnasse
c'est au tour de versailles chantiers
d'être équipé d'un piano
un piano dans un hall de gare une
initiative originale qui n'a laissé
personne indifférent à versailles
chantiers
je me pose des questions justement mais
ça peut créer quelque chose de convivial
agréable je me dis pourvu qu'on abîme
pas trop le piano innovator ya des
masques qui a copié l'arrestation
l'idée nous est venue suite à
l'installation d'un preneur d'un piano à
montparnasse
l'idée aussi de créer une ambiance comme
sa chaleureuse et un peu nouvelle dans
une grande gare de banlieue
et puis à l'occasion de l'arrivée de ce
piano qu'on a acheté que notre service à
acheter on s'est dit pourquoi pas
créer un concert en 81
rémi français employés de la sncf a
enfilé son costume de pianiste amateur
pour l'occasion accompagné de michael
green au professeur au conservatoire de
versailles
ils ont interprété pour les usagers de
la gare des pièces de beethoven ou
encore brad
cynique siens significative ça devrait
se faire plus souvent dans les gares les
aéroports important parce qu'il ya des
pianistes on en trouve ses pinceaux
sissao des musiciens il y en a partout
un piano en libre accès à la disposition
des usagers de la guerre des chantiers
pour faire naître une nouvelle ambiance
rapprocher les agents des clients et
fuir la routine des gares de banlieue
l'idée séduit mais qu'en est il de la
sécurité
il peut se passer des choses sur ce cas
ne sais pas comment il vivra donc on l'a
placé dans laxe delà de l'espace ou
travail des agents pour que les agents
puissent le voir et faire en sorte de le
protéger afin de pallier à d'éventuels à
devant toi le problème s'il ya des gens
qui essaient de dégrader l'achat du
piano aura coûté 3400 euros reste à
calculer le prix de la maintenance
technique après l'installation d'un tel
instrument en gare de paris montparnasse
versailles-chantiers devient le deuxième
pays à nos gares d'île de france
l'instrument de musique occupera le haut
pendant plusieurs mois afin d'évaluer la
réussite de l'opération
un petit morceau malatesta hangar c'est
possible c'est envisageable
tout à fait c'est un cadre particulier
dans la zone ont sonné le taux ça vous
êtes arrivé déjà de jouer dans des
cadres comme ça pas surprenant oui dans
les centres commerciaux
ces particules gens qui faisaient leurs
courses régime de l'ère du métal
d'accord ça devait être surprenants ils
étaient prévenus avant non létale est un
bien grand mot
c'est vrai effectivement les projets
peut-être dû laisser ma très rapidement
en termes de concerts on
joli partenariat avec la garden café
quand ils se trouvent place d'un des
gones est justement à côté de la gare et
donc on organise des concerts jazz donc
le 8 février
il y aura une jam session voilà c'est la
deuxième édition
puis on est parti pour un long
partenariat avec eux c'est extrêmement
agréable on est très bien accueilli et
puis 19 janvier voilà et le 23 février
note 20 février les êtres févier aussi
donc dans la même salle la salle paul
gauguin qui se trouve rue jacques
brugnon il y aura aussi trois groupes
unis montrent un ont fait on met en
avant des jeunes groupies lui ni mon
teint et on sera dans une ambiance très
pop rock et le 10 janvier dans cette
même salle il y aura le concert de
malatesta données nous envie d'y aller
un mot ou deux des nombreux j'ai fait
c'est pas mal de le voir a dit merci
donc à tous les deux un rappel peut-être
aussi en ce qui concerne oscar b
rendez vous vendredi 8 février au
scarabée de la verrière pour tous les
amoureux de flamenco of cuisine et
cuisine oui on va partir à guyancourt
pour un atelier de souci on a faim le
repas approche est juste après et bien
nous recevons l'artiste charles gonzalez
en représentation à la maison de la
poésie au menu de cet atelier de cuisine
japonaise sushis et california maquis
pour les quinze inscrits entouré du chef
chauray rhein et jian pour la deuxième
année consécutive l'atelier proposé à
guyancourt fait découvrir en toute
simplicité les bases de la cuisine
japonaise
après un cours sur la cuisson du riz et
la découpe des sushis les participants
ont créé leur propre recette ainsi
saumon crevettes avocats ou encore
feuilles de menthe et cacahuètes
tout peut être roulé dans le riz la chef
apporte tous les ingrédients et des
ustensiles nécessaires à l'arrêt
isation d'un sushi et d'un maquis
j'insiste beaucoup sur la qualité des
produits d'abord c'est à dire que le
poisson doit être enfin montré frais on
n'achète pas dans un étal de supermarché
on va au marché on en parle à son
poissonnier on le fait préparer donc
c'est la fraîcheur déjà qui va faire la
qualité du sushi et aussi le fait de pas
sont intoxiqués vous pouvez si vous
voulez mélange et probablement aussi une
encre vêtements ça va très bien ensemble
avec la cacahuète
j'avais beaucoup cuisiner et on m'en
avait parlé l'année dernière des
ateliers l'année dernière et c'est à
dire dans logicien s'inscrire voilà on
est venu avec des communes c'est
plaisant à manger donc je me suis dit
que je pouvais peut-être le faire
moi-même comment ça se passe a
finalement ne sais pas si difficile que
ça j'ai les mains et je pense que non le
race a été sans difficulté aucune
un second atelier de cuisine japonaise
pourrait à ce programme et au cours de
cette année